hasta hace poco esta carretera estaba
controlada por las fuerzas rusas que se
retiraron de esta estratégica ciudad del
sur de ucrania nikolái para los
habitantes el repliegue es un motivo de
esperanza la bandera ucraniana vuelve a
ondear en by estanca una localidad que
había sido tomada por el ejército ruso a
pocos kilómetros del centro de mykolaiv
en este campo se observan los rastros de
la presencia rusa este camión utilizado
para lanzar cohetes fue destruido por
los ucranianos que defendieron su ciudad
este vehículo pasaba por nuestro barrio
así que les bajamos los neumáticos y
terminó aquí lo destrozamos por completo
tras semanas de intensos combates contra
las fuerzas rusas las tropas ucranianas
consiguen ganar terreno estoy muy
orgulloso de nuestro ejército esta
ciudad ha sido blanco de bombardeos los
civiles están conmocionados este era mi
casa a pesar de todo circula cierto
alivio por el retiro de los rusos han
destruido todas estas casas la gente se
ha ido no puede pasarnos nada peor pero
al menos las fuerzas rusas se tuvieron
que marchar la amenaza ha desaparecido
por el momento de mikko life donde
impera un deseo de calma tras los
continuos bombardeos desde el inicio de
la invasión rusa para moscú mykolaiv es
un pivote para alcanzar el control del
puerto de odessa pero de momento la
ciudad ha logrado resistir a la ofensiva
de rusia